on voit bien qu'il y avait entre le
discours d'hier et le discours
d'aujourd'hui une vraie différence
et quand le couple exécutif expliqué
qu'ils auraient le cap devant le congrès
et ensuite le détail devant le parlement
très clairement de ce produit là le
compte y est si je dois m'efforcer
d'être objectif c'était un peu long je
le dis avec l'amitié que je porte à
edouard philippe
mais à l'intérieur pour le court
il y avait effectivement des annonces
concrètes et précises dans lesquelles on
retrouve à la fois une partie des
promesses du candidat mâcon et dans le
même temps une ligne à laquelle quand on
appartient à la droite convient à droite
et du centre on a eu des soutiens de
chuter dans laquelle on se retrouve
aussi quand on explique qu'il faut être
capable de trouver une voie entre une
réforme de l'asie en faire les choses de
manière prompte et en même temps une
lutte contre l'immigration irrégulière
quand on explique qu'il vous faire en
sorte que le travail puisse se payer
davantage quand tiers des positions qui
consiste à expliquer que la restauration
de notre souveraineté le redressement de
notre pays
ça passe par le fait de mieux tenir les
comptes publics se sont évidemment
autant d'éléments avec lesquels je ne
peux être que d'accord satisfaits et
enthousiaste ce que sont des
orientations